dans le niveau
karina qu'on fait à pradines
allez
on cherche un type un dénommé stahl 1
connaît pas même de nom un mystère de la
semaine on connaît personne de ce nom et
elle vous la connaissez céline et moi
aussi
on sait que ce stan est un dealer de
clics
on vient de te le dire on connaît pas ce
mec là il ya eu un meurtre
on doit absolument lui parler
vas-y au côté de lui je bouge pas ne
bouge pas on s'en va c'est toi qui bouge
pas les olympiens peuvent lâcher là je
voulais croire fils a pu écouter écouter
une enquête sur le meurtre d'une jeune
fille au jardin botanique
rien de plus on n'a rien contre qu'est
ce que vous cherchez pas c'est un peu
l'âme du canet avec toi pour ta gueule
ni grosse je ne suis pas un trou du cul
un faux-pas triper fait pas les convois
de sony aux petits oignons on est des
policiers les blancs l'air qu'est ce que
la le fais tu plais pourquoi il trompe
pas les mots je te dit de fermer
capitaine 30